こんにちは
[音楽]
ドクターはじめだ
皆さん
清涼飲料水好きでしょうか俗称10この
世の中にはゼウスというものが非常に多
すぎてどれを飲めばいいかわからないと
かなり多いと思うそしてどれも最高に
美味しい迷う選べない困ったそんな
科学者の声が上がっております私の学会で
そこでドクターはじめ思いました
今までのドクター始めはバカだった今まで
のドクター初めだったらきっとこれ全部
混ぜて何味になるの
みたいな雑な企画をやってたと思うんです
けどもドクターはじめ成長しました今日は
しっかりホワイトボードとかも準備しまし
たそして今回しっかり考えるので女性も
呼んでおりますよろしく
頼んだよろしくお願いします
されている500mlのペットボトルの
ジュースお茶とか水を省きましたペット
ボトルの甘い飲み物だけを全て集めました
おそらく合計116種類ありますおそらく
今販売されているものはこれで全てです
静岡市内では
わかんないけど今回の時期はこれらの
組み合わせ配合を考えて超甘党の私
ドクターはじめが思う一番おいしい
ジュースの組み合わせは何かを本気で考え
たいと思いますそしたらジュースって目に
入るものなので色とかも大事なのかもしれ
ないこれからの研究のうちで何がいいのか
しっかりこう一番美味しいジュースの
組み合わせ配合率とかこの中の組み合わせ
次第ではもう黄金の組み合わせが絶対ある
と思うんですよそれをぜひとも
商品化してくださいこの
ドリンクを探し出したいと思います
美味しい
ニュース僕のこれが今回の研究テーマです
[音楽]
でもあのそこら辺の子供たちとか小学生が
やるとかわけが違って私29歳大人がやり
ますからこれですよ研究には取れる下がる
のでちょっとあれ太く
している
マーカーだね今回の実験を終了だけどマジ
でもうこのフォントで行くしかない
からこれを太くしちゃうけど私はその間に
1回全ての飲み物を試飲します
完全に住所っていうジャンルなのか
乳製品なのかとか何からすればいいん
だろうね一番好きなのですかベスト5
ぐらいはあるんですけどこの中のベスト5
を選ぶとしたらまずドクターペッパー
めっちゃ好きなんですよこれ1ゴールの
ペットボトルめっちゃ好きですあ
スコールマジで好きですねいやコカコーラ
も結局のブスね
戦争ポケットはガムのみメロンソーダなん
となく私ドクターはじめのベスト5こちら
のメンバーになりますねでも本当に
子供っぽいのが好きってのは結構あると
思いますね私というわけでまずは全て
とりあえず試飲しつつあの1回全部混ぜ
さしてください今のこれドクターはじめの
宿命というかあのもう性癖なのよ1回全て
の合計値を見たいので全部進出同じ要領分
この中に混ぜていきたいと思うがぶ飲み
メロンもそうだいただきます
一生
[音楽]
飲めそうスコール
1号令
ミルキードクターペッパー
フルーティ我らがコカコーラ
最高だぜぐんぐんぐると
身長伸びた
ハルビスウォーター
選手の味三ツ矢サイダー
青春の味デカビタ青春の味
りんご100%ジュース
濃いですね100%とかマッチサウナ
上がりとかめっちゃ飲みますねライフ
ガード一時期はまってて美味しいです
カルビスソーダ美味しいコカコーラプラ
美味しいスッキリしてますメルチ香る
ぶどうんいい匂いコカコーラー甘い
スプライトうまいマジうまいラインナップ
この辺ファンタオレンジファンタ
オレンジャーの飲んでますよいただきます
[音楽]
ファンタグレープ最高ファンタメロン
ゴージャスなっちゃんそのままりんご
そのままりんごキリンレモン
キリンレモンペプシーハンターミステリー
ブルー
色やば色ソートやばい車いただきます
わからん体から来てBを
汗のラリーフレッシュうんアセロラ今の
ところうんこですけど大丈夫ですか
いろんな
色が混ざるとどうしても色がねちょっと
濁ってしまいますが大事な味なので続いて
三ツ矢サイダーおいしい
国産ミルクカルピス甘い
ジンジャーエール
ミューレモン&オレンジ飲みやすい梅
ソルティ
夏とか飲みたい味ですね
PD密林アップリーダー
ブルーシャにぶどうゼリー冷やしてゼリー
凍らせてシャーベットになるみたいな食感
を楽しむタイプのやつね
ドロドロしてる
ごめん
全部飲んじゃった俺ゼリー好きだから結構
この手好きなんですよね
キリラブズスポーツスポーティーミュウ
スポーツうんSpotifyマルシモリ
グレープスパークリングうん
バークリーンカルピスソーダ
電解質他にセット
昔子供の頃ポカリの面積って虫もたくさん
できましたハンター青春すぎて
飲みやすいまろやか1番のミルおいしい
クラフト5種類買ってたフルートですごい
ねボスでフルーツール出てるんだコーヒー
のイメージしかなかった
リアルゴールドチャージ
撃甲羅
2本果物はね太陽トロピアノ100%
オレンジオレンディーこれ全然オリティ
ですねあーでも飲みやすい空気
力です
ボディメンテメンテージもダブル
レモンターさんにグリーンアップルおお
ほぼ水まあビタミンアップルアップ小岩
純粋リンゴンギーこれは純粋
クリームソーダ
CGレモンCCダブルビットミーwith
そんな皮ごとすり潰さくれぴー京都
レモネード清水です
オランジーナーフトレハンタープレミア
レモンプレミアプレミアム
プレミアムサイディー
グリーンだから
フロント神社
オレンジですか
飲みやすい国産
アレルギーでなんか口ぶつぶつできちゃう
んだよねこれウォーターいますか
なこれアミノサプリメント
なっちゃん塩パン1枚ビール
キリットレンジャーの番号
ミックスジュースまな板メロンでこいつが
ちょっと一時速度の見たわーいほんと
スパークリング大分のなしそうだうまい
しなブドウだうまいヘルシェビッグ生0
じゃない方うまいクンゴ
ー
飲み過ぎちゃったというわけで全種類の
ペットボトルのジュース一応新させて
いただきました
どれがどの足したか覚えてませんただ
美味しくないって思ったのは一つもなかっ
たんですよそれほどに魅力的にあるこの
ジュースたちここから僕のお気に入りの味
に近づけるために色々と日々研究していき
たいと思いますというわけでこれが現状の
ペットボトルで売っているジュースを全て
合わせた飲み物になりますとりあえず飲ん
でみますいただきますいってら
[音楽]
ミックスジュースで薄ないですかちょっと
水のさいろはすとかも入ってるし
ジュース貼りの味の濃さを薄まってる気が
するあーなるほどなるほどさっぱりさを
抜いておいしさを皆さんであれば1回透明
な色発のちょっと味がついてるやつとかは
省いてもいいのかもしれないこれいいこと
に気づきますねこれちょっとサンプリング
しても
[音楽]
行け貴重なサンプリングが
はいというわけで
本日は約1リットル以上のジュースを
あげるように飲んでしまい私も味の判断が
つきませんので今日はここまでにしたいと
思いますまた明日の研究でお会いし
ましょうおやすみ
はいというわけで2日目です今日から本格
的に混ぜていく実験をしていこうと思う
今日はとりあえず
乳製品と炭酸を混ぜるのは基本的に僕は
ないと思ってまして
そうでもないかカルピスソードあるもんな
お前誰だなんでうちの中にいるんだお前出
てけ侵入したいんですとりあえず今日は
種類分けしていきましょう1回乳製品だ
けど分けてみてもいいですお願いします
よし
クリーム
そうだそれが何だ
[音楽]
じゃあなんとなく出揃いましたでこういう
なんか体にいい系のカルピスとかあるじゃ
ないですかこれは味ではなく体にいい
ところの重視してるので今回からは買っ
といた方がいい気がするんですよカルビス
ウォーターとかもこれカルピスと
ウォーターで水の部分があるのでこれを
足かせにはなっていますね
全然違うわグングングルトいきます
見えましたよ
せーの
おー
すごいビックルなんだ一番うまかったそれ
がやっぱ濃いもの優先して行った方が
混ぜた時に
味が良くなるからちょっと薄いのはぶって
いきましょうほら気づけはもうこんなに
乳製品が絞られてきましたうわ究極の2択
行っちゃいますよこれ1ゴール対1番の
ミルクおそらく5歳なレベルだと思うん
ですよ両方テーマは一緒なのでどっちが
美味しいか検証してみたいと思います
いただきます
うまっ
次いちごオレです作ります
なるほどなるほどいきますはい
せーの
おー
いやなんかこっちに美味しいんですけど
我々みたいなその現代以降にはポチの方が
向いてるかもしれないっていう
わかんない仮説ですあくまでというわけで
乳酸飲料はこちらになりましたというわけ
で次のフェーズに移ろう次は乳酸飲料以外
のジュースの残りを準備したドクター
はじめの下の味的にはもう苦味成分があっ
た瞬間アウトだと思うんですよ僕苦いの嫌
なんでなるべく甘くて透き通った最高の
笑ったのかお前は
何がおかしい
ぞ
1回苦いと思った省いてていいですかそれ
は絶対今回の事件いらないと思います1回
飲み送ります
ぶち殺すぞすいません
はいというわけである程度源泉にできまし
たここが一応生き残ったメンツですはいと
いうわけでここからはかなり数が絞れたの
でいろんな組み合わせをひたすら試して
試して試して実験思考を繰り返し最高の味
にたどり着きたいと思いますというわけで
ちょっと個人的
[音楽]
に色はそんな美味しかったそうです
飲んでみます
すごい銃だねこれもすごいそれおいしいん
すかね
特別な味この組み合わせはないですね一番
のミルク+バナナのミルク出してメロン&
ミルク
いただきます
[音楽]
うまいちょっと飲んでみてほしい
うまっこうだったペプチ1対1
[音楽]
夢のコラボレーションだねなんかペプシス
の良さもコカコーラの良さもちゃんとある
これはこれでかなり一つの完成形を見た気
がしました今パンダグレープ
ファンタメロンファンタオレンジ1体1対
いただきます
もぎもぎフルーツスイカドリンクと
スコール1体1
ヤクルト
[音楽]
柑橘系炭酸飲料1体1体1体
痛い痛い痛い
未完ソーダみたいなやつだった
布陣のパンツみたいな話普通に下着の夢に
なっちゃったけど
[音楽]
すぐ味がする
疲れた時に飲む栄養剤
カルピスソーダ味なのマジで梨が効いてる
ちゃんと
惜しいな美味しいけど美味しい
商店地は言えないって感じ
ケミカルの味になっちゃったこれなんか
好きな人は好きそうでも
[音楽]
なんかめっちゃ煙ですね
はいというわけでお疲れ様でした二日間
ぐらいがっつりかけて色々研究して
完成しました
事実だけを先に言わせていただきましょう
完璧はありませんでした
ジュースというものは飲料を作られる会社
が長い期間をかけて作られたものなので
ほとんど全部完成してるんですよつまり
混ぜると美味しくなくなるということに私
気づきまして途中でそこで今回3つの部門
に分けさせていただきますまず1つ目色
部門いろんな絨毯あるんですけどもやっぱ
色に惹かれて買う人もいると思いますが
特に綺麗な色の組み合わせ発見しました色
部分はこちらです
ファンタメロンとファンタミステリーこの
組み合わせが本当に綺麗でした
混ぜてみます1対1ぐらいでめっちゃ綺麗
になるんですよ
見てくださいこの美しいエメラルドブルー
パリピみたいなんですけども光を当てると
すごく綺麗に発色します
めっちゃ綺麗でしょこれ
ジュースの色なんですよ
感動しちゃうで味の方も飲んでみたいと
思います
[音楽]
普通になんかケミカルな味はするんです
けどもとても美味しいです
続いてはね乳製品部門です
色々なんですけどもやっぱり炭酸の
ジュースと乳製品がどうしても噛み合わ
なくて乳製品の中で一番美味しいであろう
組み合わせこちらでしたまろやか1番の
ミルク呪いがバナナミルクまろやかな&
ミルクとビックル1対1体1体1の
組み合わせですなここ3つは同じ販売元な
のでまあ美味しいとしてそれにビッグルを
加えるとなお美味しくなることが我々の
緊急で判明しました早速飲んでみましょう
はいこういう感じです色はびっくりみたい
に戻ってしまったんですけどもすげー
フルーティーで美味しいんですよいただき
ます
[音楽]
お金色んなフルーツミックスオールとか
あるんですけどもマジでこの3人が絶妙に
バランスがかみ合っててイチゴバナナ
メロン全ての良さが出ておりびっくりで
さらに味もこう上乗せされていておそらく
乳製品飲料の中ではこれかなり上位に来る
のかなと思いました
美味しいですそして最後炭酸ジュース部門
ですねこれ
本当に難しかったです全部完成してるん
ですよ完成している中でも組み合わせて
美味しかったのこちらになります
ウォーターメロンスイカの
ドリンクスコールがぶ飲みメロンソーダ
ファンタメロン700メロン&ミルク
メロン揃いで飲むとめちゃくちゃ
美味しかったですなんかコーラとかも色々
試してみたんですけどもやっぱり何か
噛み合わなかったり喧嘩して長い時間かけ
て色々やってみた結果これが一番
美味しかったですもう混ざっているので
早速飲んでみたいと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
なんかね
本当うまくいかないんですけどこれだけ
奇跡的にうまくいっててガブ飲みメロン
相談の上位互換みたいな感じの味わいでし
たというわけで今回の実験2日間にかけて
頑張らせていただいたんですけれども
なかなか難しかったですですがこちら色が
綺麗なドリンクそして乳製品の美味しい
ドリンク炭酸ジュースの美味しいドリンク
一応我々の中で答えは出たんですけども
まだ我々の知らない美味しいドリンクある
と思うので皆さん是非色々試してみて
ください
ほぼまずいです女子のありがとうじゃあな
[音楽]